this is a production of Cornell
University um thanks for joining guys my
name is beia zal I am a second year PhD
student here at Cornell studying plant
breeding and genetics under Larry smart
with a focus on hemp so um I wanted to
kick off this webinar series by saying
how excited I am that this is the third
year that we're hosting this and I I'd
like to thank Cornell agratech um for
the funding to make this possible and
then also our collaborators at USDA the
hemp drum plasm repository particularly
Zachary stanil who was um important for
founding this webinar series and then
also the pl past grad students that ran
this um George stack in the first year
and Luis monserate last year so I'm very
excited to pick up the Baton and keep
this going and I think we have a really
excellent lineup of hemp experts and I
hope you all like really enjoy the the
content they have for you because I
think they have some interesting talks
so again Feel Free as webinar is going
to type up your questions put those in
the Q&A box and then when the speaker is
done with this talk we'll go through
those any other messages you know you
can do direct messaging to each other
even should go in the chat box so again
questions in the Q&A box everything else
in the chat box
so thanks for joining us I'd like to
welcome our first Speaker of the series
David suchoff Dr suchoff is an assistant
professor and alternative crops
extension specialist with NC State his
program is focused on collaborative and
applied field-based research in new and
emerging crops particularly as
replacement for tobacco cultivation uh
his current crops include a wide variety
fiber and grain hemp Sesame organic
sunflower and fiber flax he also serves
as the Director of the foundation for
food and agriculture research hemp
research
Consortium and that is a a public
private partnership that aims to address
key industry challenges in the National
hemp space through research and
Outreach thank you deid for being our
first speaker and that take it away
great well first off beia thank you so
so much uh Kim as well thank you um it's
really an honor to be part of this I was
I was looking at the lineup of speakers
that you all have planned for this year
and it's uh quite a tremendous lineup
and I'm certainly looking forward to
attending and listening to to the other
speakers I also want to thank everybody
else for attending today um it's it's
nice to see some familiar names on the
list even though I can't see your faces
yet but uh additionally it's nice to see
a lot of new folks as well as folks from
I see someone from France now but but I
saw Zimbabwe and and Uruguay and
Argentina so I this is just a really
really uh wonderful webinar series that
you all host so uh as Bia mentioned my
name is David suchoff I'm a faculty
member here in the department of crop
and soil Sciences at NC State and um my
position as as mentioned is alternative
crops extension specialist and so what I
wanted to do today is to first kind of
discuss what that means what does my
position mean why do we do what we do um
and then we're going to delve a little
bit into North Carolina agriculture uh
and then really spend the majority of
our time talking about fiber him and
I'll admit that the title of the talk is
somewhat misleading the title is
production recommendations for textile
fiber um and it's misleading because we
are still very much learning what those
recommendations are um and so a lot of
the research that we're doing with fiber
hemp is actually quite new many of the
trials that we've initiated that I'll be
talking about today started this past
summer so so uh any of the data that
I'll be sharing is very much preliminary
um it's giving us a better idea in terms
of how we need to move when it comes to
to production recommendations but um
just know that a lot of this is very
much preliminary uh and we're looking
forward to kind of continuing on with
this work and expanding uh further so
let me go ahead and share my
screen okay can you all see
that I'm assume you can um yes thank you
so um let's first talk a little bit
about North Carolina for those of you
that may not know much about the state
um agriculture is big in North Carolina
um it is our number one industry in
terms of um economics this past year in
2023 we received just a little over
hundred billion do in sales of all these
different uh agricultural goods and this
was the first time that we broke a
hundred billion dollar so not only is it
a large industry but it is still a very
uh important uh and um ever growing
industry the other interesting fact
about North Carolina is that um our
agriculture sector is the third most
diverse in the nation we are only behind
California and Florida which I think is
um pretty impressive given the size of
our state compared to uh Florida and
California now a lot of this has to do
with the fact that even though we're
relatively small we're quite long and
we've got a a lot of different
geographies ranging from the coast all
the way to the mountains so we've got
different soil types different climates
different microclimates and so on
um now even though this is a very
diverse agricultural system there are
certain crops that have been more
important economically speaking than
others uh and one in particular is
tobacco um if you don't know North
Carolina and agriculture know that
tobacco built this state and it still is
an important crop in our state um though
as you all probably guessed tobacco
acdes down right consumption of tobacco
is down globally and so ACD is going
down with it uh and so unfortunately
what we're seeing is many of the
counties or regions in our state where
tobacco has been prominent and really
did build up those communities are going
through a lot of economic hardship and
depression and they're having challenges
finding some alternative crop to be
either a full or partial replacement for
tobacco and so that's where my position
comes in my position is a new one in the
college that was developed about five
years ago and it was created
specifically to look at new emerging
crops that can fit in a traditional
tobacco system as either a full or
partial replacement for Farmers that are
either already out of tobacco or are
starting to kind of you know make their
way out of that production system and so
I guess the first question is well what
are the crops do they grow um now the
majority of tobacco production occurs in
the eastern part of the state and if you
look basically these are traditional row
cropping systems meaning there's corn
production there's soy production and
there's wheat production and tobacco is
fitting in uh that rotation and so when
we're looking at alternative crops we
really want to be looking at crops that
can also fit Within These systems um so
something that is going to leverage the
same type of equipment or infrastructure
that is shared among these uh systems uh
and so um when we are thinking about new
crops we really need to keep that in
mind now um taken together when when
we're talking about our program we look
at a number of different crops so be had
mentioned we look at hemp we've been
working at on hemp since I first started
admittedly when when I first started
most of our work was in canabo or floral
hemp because that's where the industry
was um but that was somewhat of a bubble
that burst and we're seeing a huge shift
towards fiber and so we are moving with
that uh shift as well but we also work
with with sunflowers as beia mentioned
um we're working a lot with Sesame um
flax and a few other crops and there's
kind of Three core aspects of our
program the first is agronomics I am am
an agronomist by training and so that's
the type of work that we're doing we
want to understand a if we can even grow
the crop here and then B what is it that
we need to do from a production
standpoint to ensure that we are
producing that crop at the highest
standard we also focus on sustainability
and we really do try to focus on the
three tenants of sustainability that is
economic viability environmental
sustainability and then social equity
and when we're looking at these new
crops we really want to make sure that
we're looking at all three of those and
then the last one is this concept of
quality um one of the things that has
made made tobacco so special for our
state is that we are able to produce a
very specific type of highquality
tobacco which is often referred to as
you know the Golden Leaf the flu cured
Golden Leaf Tobacco of North Carolina
and why that's important and the reason
why I bring that up is that it is a
product that is recognized across the
globe and it generates higher profit
margins and so when we are looking at
these new and emerging crops we want to
make sure that we are taking that
mindset that is I want folks in a
different part of the world to know that
okay sesame from North Carolina or Fiber
hemp from North Carolina is of high
quality because that means that our
farmers can uh Garner the highest
profits now we're going to talk a little
bit about quality and fiber hemp and the
challenges that we've had in terms of um
what that actually means but but we'll
get to that in in a little bit now as I
mentioned we saw this big boom and bust
around floral hemp and a big shift
towards fiber hemp um and what's
exciting for North Carolina is that it's
not just farmer interest in fiber but
we're seeing a lot of interest from
processors uh and use manufacturers and
so this brings me to the next important
aspect of our state to know and that is
that textiles is still also a very
important uh industry in our city now
admittedly this industry is not what it
was you know 20 years ago a 100 years
ago there's been a tremendous amount of
offshoring of textiles but it still
generates quite a lot of money as you
could see close to one and a half
billion dollars in 2023 we have almost
400 textile manufacturers in our state
and these range from you know mom and
pop very small scale handmade products
to very very large processors like you
see in the photo here uh and large
apparel Brands um and what's also really
important to note is that our state
produces about 20% of the nation's
export of textille so yes the industry
is not what it used to be but it still
is a very very important industry to the
state and this industry is particularly
interested in fiber and when I talk to
these folks whether it is apparel
companies that want to integrate fiber
hemp into some of their apparel lines or
if it's non-woven companies they want to
include it into some of their non-woven
products they are really excited about
fiber hemp and it's not just simply the
novelty of saying you know this shirt
contains hemp but there are actual
benefits to the Garment or to the non-
moven product that that fiber from fiber
hemp affords them and so they're really
excited about that and they're also
really excited about the the
sustainability story that's associated
with fiber Hamp and we can certainly
spend spend some time talking about that
a bit later on so I I'm going to go over
some Basics and I apologize because I'm
sure there are plenty of people on this
this call that know this information but
it's going to be important if you don't
know it that you do because we're going
to talk about this later on but when
we're talking about fiber hemp
production we're really talking about
stem farming right all we're after is
producing nice long thin stems the
reason for that is that's where the
fibers are located and the fibers are
located in the bast in particular so the
bast is uh basically the Ark of the stem
and that's where these very very long
very strong cellulosic fibers are
located that we can use for clothing or
yarn or non-woven materials and so on
and so forth there's also the herd right
which is that inner Woody core and you
know historically it's been used for
animal bedding but we're seeing a lot of
really really interesting Innovations
around hempcrete or or other
applications of herd in fact the herd
Market in the US is growing much faster
than the bast Market is and there's a
number of reasons
why but when we talk talk about textile
application it's also important to
understand that there are a number of
processes that are required to go from
harvesting in the field to something
that can then be spun or woven or
incorporated into you know name your
garment or name your non-woven product
and so we're going to cut our crop and
we're going to let it R and so during
that rting process we're leaving it in
the field and during that time period as
long as the environment is correct
microbes are going to be breaking down
the pectin that binds together the bast
and herd which is critical for our next
step which is decortication so after
it's readed we take that stem material
out of the field to a decorticator and
all a decorticator is is just a set of
it's most basic a set of rolling uh
gears that crush the stems and if the
stems are properly readed the herd will
separate from the bast so we've got a
pile of herd and we've got a pile of
Bast once it's decorticated we then take
that Bast to our next and final step
which is De guming and D guming is just
pulping so we're going to take that Bast
we're going to put it in a big bath
that's going to be water maybe sodium
hydroxide maybe uh hydrogen peroxide
maybe some other products and what we're
we're going to add heat and pressure and
we're cooking it so that we can more or
less wash away the impurities mainly
ligan and hemicellulose so there's other
stuff in there that we're trying to get
rid of so that when we are done with de
guming all we have are those cellulosic
fibers that we can then send to the the
the textile or unwoven companies and
what's really exciting in North Carolina
to my knowledge and I may be may be
incorrect in saying this we are the only
state that has both decortication
facilities and degumming Facilities um
and this is going to be really critical
when we think about the longterm picture
with fiber him um you know we are
certainly doing a lot of shipping of
materials from state to state but I
think when we you know talk about this
crop really becoming a commodity crop in
the United States we're going to have to
see a lot more um close processing of
these materials because shipping costs
money and this is bulky material so
we've got a number of dumers we've got a
number of decorators and then we also
have a number of spinners and Weavers
and so on and so forth and so what what
I like to see is yes there's interest
from Farmers but also there's interest
from local processors that want that
material and that really is critical
when we think about looking at a new
crop because if there's no demand and
there's nowhere to sell it why is a
farmer going to grow it now when we talk
about the research that we're doing at
NC State at least in my program as I
mentioned I'm in a gr
and so we are looking at trying to
address some of the basic production
challenges that farmers have to ensure
that they can produce a sustainable
fiber crop and so I've got a list of uh
some of the different projects that my
program is working on but the other
thing that I wanted to highlight is that
we're doing a lot of really interesting
collaborations within the university um
so we're working a lot with folks in our
College of Natural Resources they're
looking more at um the pulping side of
things and the use of herd for uh paper
and packaging uh and uh s sanitation uh
uh materials and then of course we're
also doing a lot more collaboration with
folks in our Wilson College of textiles
they of course are interested in
applications of of this material in
apparel and non-woven materials and you
know this is always a plug if you're
ever in North Carolina you've got to
visit the College of textiles because
the work they do there is just
absolutely incredible and they are
really really excited about fiber Hamp
and they're doing some very very cool
things with fiber hemp when it comes to
you know developing new types of
garments or new ways of spinning and
incorporating hemp into um more
traditional lines so we do basic
agronomic work and we collect all
different types of data um but at the
end of the day there's two main pieces
of data that are really important for
Farmers quantity and quality right
that's how I'm paid how many pounds of
tomatoes did I produce produce per acre
and what's the grade of tomato that I
produced because that's going to dictate
how I get paid now measuring quantity is
easy I can measure the amount of dry
reded straw and then I can decorticate
and I can measure the vast yields easy
enough quality is an issue the reason
for that is we do not yet have a set of
um International or even national uh
standards Universal standards when it
comes to fiber quality now that's not to
say that people don't know what quality
is you know a Nike or a VF or a
Patagonia may have their definition of
of of quality but when you look at other
fiber crops like cotton there are USDA
um standards for cotton and it makes
grading cotton very easy but it also
makes our job as researchers easy too
because we can look at the different
treatments that we're applying in the
field and then relate that back to
Quality and so in the absence of of
these quality metrics and I will say as
an aside there are many groups working
on this and so it's just a matter of
time before we get them we are trying to
think about how we measure quality and I
like to think of quality in two uh bins
one is just the basic fiber morphology
right if you're to separate that fiber
out you can measure its length its
diameter or its daire which is kind of
the the diameter of of the the fiber its
T Cell strength so on and so forth so
these are just basic morphological uh
properties of the fiber we can certainly
do that in fact we've got equipment that
can do that but there's another uh
bucket which is what I'm calling
processability how easy is it to
decorticate meaning how easy is it to
separate the herd from the vast how much
cellulose is in there and how much
lignan and hemicellulose other um
impurities are in there because that's
going to digate uh uh that's going to
um that's going to dictate uh how much
energy and resources are going to be
required to deum it this is very very
important the reason why is if it
requires a lot more energy to
decorticate or a lot more energy and
inputs to De gum you will quickly
overwhelm any of the benefits you see in
the fiber quality you're going to affect
the strength of the fiber you may even
damage the actual fibers cut them and so
on and so forth and so what we're doing
is trying to focus on both but a lot of
our work right now is actually focusing
more on processability how can we
produce stems that are easy to
decorticate and that require the least
amount of chemistry chemistries or
energy and so on and so forth to degum
because not only is that going to reduce
the cost Downstream but that should uh
keep us from damaging those fibers then
we can start doing work whether it's
Larry smart breeding for different types
of fibrom morphologies or or uh looking
at some of the other um you know
agronomic practices to affect those
those different uh morphological
properties
so let's jump into one of the first
challenges we had and the first
challenge uh is beautifully Illustrated
in this picture I think I use in every
one of my talks this is a picture from
2019 uh in hemp grower magazine and uh
it's taken in North Carolina there was a
really nice article about uh this
interest in fiber hemp in our state uh
the gentleman on the left is Gary Sykes
he is a hemp farmer and the gentle
gentlem on the right is tamour AAR who
is a um uh CEO of a hemp decortication
company in North Carolina and they're
standing in a field of what should have
been fiber hemp that Gary planted now
with fiber hemp we're going to harvest
this crop at the onset of flowering
there's a couple reasons why one
generally speaking we're not going to
gain a lot more in terms of stem height
though we certainly do see some
increasing growth in in uh uh certain
varieties even during flowering but the
other is that we're going to have an
increase in secondary fiber production
in the stems we're going to have an
increase of ligant so goes back to
processability it's going to be harder
to process and it's going to affect uh
that fiber quality but you could see
that uh Gary and Tamar are standing in a
field that's maybe three feet tall um
you know for this crop to be uh
profitable we need to be producing at
least six eight foot tall stems uh to
produce enough biomass for to be worth
Gary's time to harvest and the issue was
that we didn't have regionally
appropriate variety
at the time we were only getting
varieties from uh you know countries
like France and Italy and Poland and it
is critical with a daylength sensitive
crop to understand where it was bred and
what the latitude was and so uh I like
to share this map and what this map is
is it's lining up the latitudes with
North America and with Europe and it
beautifully illustrates how far north
those countries are right um if we're
looking at New York for example you know
okay I think those French varieties
might be a fit for you all but even then
they're getting a little bit F farther
north but when you look down at North
Carolina where we're right around 35
degrees north we're you know North
Africa in terms of our latitude and this
is very very important because
daylengths differ so what I have here is
just a plot of uh the the the average
day length for North Carolina Raleigh
where I am right now in Ithaca New York
you all are farther north so in the
middle of the summer when you have your
longest days they're going to be longer
than ours that's just how it works well
let's look at France because a lot of
varieties were coming from France
specifically from the L Valley it's even
farther north than New York and so when
you look at their day length they're
even longer than your day lengths uh and
in fact if you look at our uh longest
day in North Carolina that light blue
that is roughly the beginning of April
meaning beginning of Spring or the
beginning of October beginning of fall
in France and so it's no wonder that
when we plant a French Variety in North
Carolina it's going to go to flower very
very early just like we saw in Gary's
field and so one of the first things
that we did was look for varieties from
different latitudes uh and we were able
to obtain genetics from China
specifically uh unan Province and so
when we look there well this is great
even farther south in North Carolina uh
so we're looking at Kon Ming right now
which is about 25 degrees north so even
farther south than us and with our first
year in looking at them much better
production much better production and a
much longer season so the individual in
this photo excuse me is Alyssa Hawker
Alyssa just completed her master's
degree and one of her projects was to
look at these new Chinese genetics at
least new to us uh in terms of their fit
for for daylength sensitivity uh and
then biomass production as well as
looking at planting dates and you know
we had a lot of issues the first year
with seed quality though uh our second
year we had really really good seed
quality and these this it was a really
really tremendous uh uh producing crop
in fact we found that the the the
flowering time was so late for us which
was usually around the beginning of
September that we really need to
reconsider when we planted the crop
because it just got too big for really
what we would consider textile grade
fiber this is what it looked like at
Harvest um it really does look like
bamboo admittedly once again as I said
this is a little bit thicker than what I
think we would want for textile purposes
generally speaking what the textile
industry says is they want it to be the
width of a number two pencil 7 and a
half millimeters uh and this is a little
bit on the thick side now even though
these were a good fit for us in terms of
dayling sensitivity there are still
added challenges that we're now trying
to address the first is just basic
economics right if I'm having to ship
seed across the globe from China there's
added cost to that and so right now seed
is around $4 a pound um and we really
want to see more domestic seed
production um you know I I I know that
there are a lot of folks including Larry
and I'll talk about that in a second
that are doing uh breeding work and
there are others uh Trey riddle who I
think was on early but I know we'll be
speaking they've got their own variety
and so you know having more domestic
seeds that work for us or other parts of
the country is going to be critical in
reducing the cost of production but
another big issue with these Chinese
genetics is that they go hot and so what
I have up here are our total THC values
that we collected from these different
varieties in 21 and
22 the Bold numbers are above 3% right
that USDA threshold and then that red
bold with the exclamation point is
getting really close to that 1%
negligent violation which is very
concern ER and you'll notice that it's
not every year that we see those values
go hot and so Larry and his crew have
done a really tremendous uh job in
looking at these Chinese genetics and
they found that they're really a
population and within that population
we'll say of Yuma Yuma one um you're
going to have individuals that still
have that Gene to produce THC and some
that don't and so when a farmer plants
this they're kind of playing Russian
roulette because there's really no way
without testing it prior to know if it's
got that Gene or not what's also
important to note is that these plants
even though they were starting to
produce male flowers were not really
truly flowering most of the material
that we were having tested was was
vegetative leaf and stem and it was
still going quite hot and so I know that
Larry has been doing breeding work we
are collaborating with Larry in
screening some of his materials uh down
south and he's I know he's working with
others uh and we're continuing to do
variety trials and so this is what our
variety trial looked like this past year
in 2023 um let me see if this
so the variety on the the bottom left
that's actually one of Larry's genetics
which looked really good you could see
not flowering uh the variety next to it
is one from Colorado and then two over
it's another from Colorado you can see
that it's already starting to flower so
once again you know it really is going
to the background in terms of where they
come from but then also where their
bread is going to be really really
important the final challenge that we
have with these Chinese genetics is what
we're calling phenotypic plasticity or
what is known as phenotypic plasticity
and what that is is just basically a
plant's ability to change its phenotype
based off of the resources that it's
given and for some reason we see that in
these Chinese varieties there's a lot
more phenotypic plasticity than there
are in the Italian varieties or in the
French varieties if you give these
Chinese varieties a lot of space they
become trees they get really thick they
produce a lot of stems and it's neat to
look at but it's really of no use from a
textille uh perspective and it's going
to be a real challenge to just Harvest
it and so um we can see that in this
picture so um this is from one of
Alyssa's first studies I believe this
variety on the left is is puma and we
had really poor seed quality but you
could see there's so much space around
that they become these thick trees with
lots of branches whereas on the right
this is Yuma one better stands though
not great but the stems are much thinner
and um they've got a lot less branching
so until we can breed out this
phenotypic plasticity which you know
that's a job for Larry we need to focus
more on plant popul
because if we look at just some of the
the basic data from alysa's study we see
that as we increase plant populations on
the
xaxis we see a decrease in stem diameter
on the y- axis that is the um basics of
of phenotypic plasticity and so this
past summer uh one of my new master
students picture on the left this is Sam
Caroll is working on a plant density
study and what Sam is doing is she's
looking at different plant stands
ranging from 300,000 plants per acre
which is very low all the way up to one
and a half million plants per acre now
how did she do this well first we
overseed our plots by about 30% and then
we came in we counted every single plant
per plot and then we thinned them out to
get the exact density that we needed for
that specific treatment was a lot of
work but it's a great study and um what
Sam did is throughout the season she was
measur measuring stem diameter and stem
height and then of course she harvested
that material and so um what I'll just
be sharing with you today are some of
the uh height and width data she's in
the process of decorticating it so we
can look at Bast and then quality and so
on and so forth so what we're looking at
here is stem height over time and these
are just plotted no hard analysis but
they once again show basic plasticity
right the black is that 300,000 per acre
and you see that it's they're going to
be taller uh and they're also going to
be a lot thicker and there also is a lot
more spread and so um what I also want
to show is the distribution of stem
diameters one of the other things that
the textile industry says that is
critical is consistency right they want
consistency in product and they want
consistency when it comes to stem
diameter and so we wanted to see how
that would affect um the distributions
right what do our stem diameters look
like within the plots and so this is
just showing the the densities of our
diameter over time so on week three and
you can see that bottom yellow is
300,000 the top is 1.5 million and look
at how wide the distribution is on
300,000 right we're just getting a very
inconsistent stem diam and so we're
really trying to focus on getting a much
narrower stem yes but also a lot more
consistency
and next what we're looking at is the
height and stem width at Harvest so we
come in we cut the stems and then we
measure them this is nothing new right
we're seeing that as we increase plant
populations our stem height goes down
which is going to happen but also that
stem diameter is going to go down and
we're getting close to that magic even
though I don't think it's really magical
7 and a half millimeters
around a million seeds per acre give or
take or I should say Pure Life seed per
acre but what's really interesting is
when we look at thinning so hemp and all
crops do what is called self thinning if
you plant enough meaning they're going
to compete with one another in a plot
and they're going to shade each other
out they're going to kill each other
until they reach an equilibrium and so
on the top plot what we have is the
perent stand thinning meaning we know
what we started with and then we know
what we ended with was there any death
that happened you know during the season
and we see that even in our 300,000
there's about 30% self thinning and that
as we increase our uh populations we're
getting an increase in thinning what's
really interesting is when we look at
our final populations so we counted in
the beginning and then we counted at the
end we see that we actually Plateau at
about
750,000 uh plants per acre right even
though we started with one and a half
million it all seems to had this
equilibrium around 700 to 750,000 now
this is one year of research we're
obviously going to be continuing this
again and we're going to look at quality
and so on um but it's really really
quite interesting and great work that
Sam has
done another project that Sam is working
on and this is uh one that we are doing
in collaboration with IND hemp is
understanding Harvest timing you can see
here here at our first harvest timing
and then at our last and so we're
looking at two varieties Yuma which is
Chinese variety and IH Williams which is
coming from IND hemp and we're looking
at different Harvest timing so quite
early on the stems are 5T tall then at
What's called the GV point which is when
there's a shift in photax so hemp
generally is opposites the leaves are
opposite one another on the stem but at
a certain point in the life cycle
generally before blooming they're going
to shift from opposite to altern it and
they're going to um basically continue
on that way so we've got five feet tall
then the GV point then male flowering
which is more or less the traditional
timing for textiles and then female
flowering which is a bit late and the
goal here is to understand yes what what
are biomass and bass yields but really
hone in on quality and then understand
what are the applications of these
fibers so let's say a fiber can't get a
farmer can't get to the crop uh until
female flowering well what can we do
with that product maybe maybe it's not
great for apparel but maybe it can go
into non- Loven just so that we can have
other ways for Farmers to get a decent
pay for their crop even if it wouldn't
be technically
ideal she also had to do water reading
for this study and or Sam as I was
putting this together I was reallying we
put her through a lot if anyone is ever
water redded it's disgusting it smells
awful um so Sam is very very dedicated
to the research um and we could
certainly talk about water breing a
little bit later weed management is
another big issue that we have in the
Southeast and in general um this year we
did have um a new well a herbicide
labeled for use which is sonland which
is great I know farmers are going to use
it but there are also a lot of farmers
that don't want to cultivate or are
already employing no till practices and
they don't want to go back to tillage
now uh this is work that's being
conducted by uh my new PhD student
Ashley George who's pictured here uh and
Ashley's got a number of projects that
I'll be talking about um and when we're
talking about weed management it's not
uncommon if Farmers have a really weedy
field in North Carolina didn't get the
right planting they didn't get good um
crop emergence we can see what happens
on the left where we just lose the field
to
weeds we also know that we can get
really good stands uh and really good
canopy closure quite early early um with
uh many of these fiber hemp varieties so
the picture on the right is roughly
canopy closure getting close to it and
that was only about three and a half
weeks after planting it's a very quick
growing crop admittedly we did use a
herbicide here and so we're looking for
alternative ways to manage weeds and so
two years ago we initiated trials using
a noil system where we plant into a
Serial Ry mulch this is a common system
for organic grain producers where they
grow cereal R over the winter they roll
it down and I'll show this in a little
bit and then they plant into it and the
idea is that that mulch acts as a weed
barrier but it still allows the crop to
come up and we did it and it didn't
really work out well for us and what we
found is that the cial Rye mulch was
simply too thick we could not get good
seed placement with our drill into that
Mulch and the reason for that is when
you look at no till corn or beans
they're not using a drill generally
speaking they're using a planter with
wider row spacing than we are with fiber
hemp at seven and a half inches
and with a planter you have a lot more
ability to move that material out of the
way that you can't do with the drill and
so we kind of steep back and reevaluated
the system and so what Ashley's doing is
she's looking at a number of other
different cover crops so yes we're
looking at seral Ry though we are
reducing the biomass that's produced
through limiting fertility applications
we're looking at tral which is another
grass that doesn't produce quite as much
biomass and then we're looking at uh two
leguminous cover crops Harry vet and
crimson clover now these two are not
used in no till traditionally because
they've got a high or excuse me a lower
carbon to nitrogen ratio so that biomass
degrades quickly and it's not going to
provide season long weed management but
that's not necessarily a problem right
because as I showed fiber hemp can get
canopy closure around three to four
weeks after planting and then once it's
off it's off it can take care of the
weeds so we really only need help those
first four weeks or so and then of
course she has a bare clean so no cover
crop that's bare and we're going to weed
it throughout the season and then a bare
weedi where we kept it clean prior
planted the hemp and then let the weeds
take over as our control and so if
you've never seen the system before we
come in with a roller crimper so you can
see we just rolled down Crim uh hary
vetch this is what I I know I shouldn't
put videos in Zoom so I hope this is
coming through okay um but this is just
a video of us rolling down cereal Ry it
is always fun to just watch um and then
we come in with a no till drill and so
the noil drill just has uh these couters
up front that cut through that residue
and open up a little bit of a seed
trench and we place the seed and then
the the closing Wheels Clos it that's it
and so she was looking at a lot of
different data obviously looking at
emergence um but what we're after is
something like this and admittedly I'd
like to see the stands a little bit
better but this is still quite good uh
this is uh fiber hemp coming through a
hary vetch Mulch and you'll notice that
we're getting decent stands though you
know as I said you could see some gaps
but not a single weed that that hary
Veet is doing a really great job at uh
reducing uh weed emergence and so let's
jump into some of these data what I've
got here are our stands at the beginning
of the season because that was an issue
in our first year of Trials um and I
I'll admit the stands are lower than we
wanted in general and so we need to work
on that but what is very important to
note is that when you look at our clean
uh uh control so that's the black box
and then our wedy clean which is this
this lightish Orange Box notice that on
the whole statistically speaking except
for in Kinston they're not different
from our no tail PL
this is really important because what
that tells us is that it's not the cover
crop that is reducing The Stance now
when we look at Kinston yes we do see
that crimson clover and Rye were
significantly lower than our um two
controls the Rye is not a huge uh
surprise given what we saw the first
year what was a big surprise is what we
saw with Harry vetch we're still
scratching our heads as to why we had
such good stands in Harry vetch I think
you know things just worked out well for
us um no till syst are quite complex uh
and there's there's a lot that goes into
getting it just right so we're going to
we're obviously continuing this work um
but we're really really happy with what
we're seeing overall especially with
Harry Veet now when we look at stands at
the end of the season we don't see any
differences and the only differences
that we do see are in Kinston and once
again higher stands Al although there is
some self- thinning right that stand is
lower than what it was at the beginning
of the season but it's got higher stands
than uh all of the other treatments so
we're feeling pretty good about that and
then when we look at just the basics of
height and diameter we see no difference
among our treatments no differences
among height in any of our locations and
no differences in Clinton or Goldsboro
when we look at our diameter which are
these these bottom to here we do see
differences in Kinston but the main
differences are really once again coming
from Harry vet higher stands means
thinner stems right we've already gone
over this and that's really what's
driving those differences there now we
want to get the stands still a little
bit better we're going to look at
quality the other thing that Ashley's
looking at too is how much biomass is
left from the cover crops at the end of
the season because remember we're going
to cut this we're going to leave it in
the field and then we're going to bail
it and so there's a big concern that
we're going to just pull up all of that
Rye or pull up all of that vetch when we
bail it um what we're seeing is there is
still some residue from our our um
luminous cover crops though it's much
much lower than what we're getting from
our uh grasses but once again we're
we're continuing on with this work and
then I want to include this cool picture
that Ashley showed so on the left of the
dotted line is our clover plot no till
and you could see that actually the
Clover went to seed and so we're getting
some of that popping up not great and
you could see through the plot so not
great stands on the right is our vetch
you can see a no vetch coming up but B
is a dense dense stand um and another
thing that we saw with Clover is you
really have to be careful about um
killing it before it goes to seed
because it can become actually a weed I
know there's a lot of talk about green
uh mulches but it really does not work
with hemp this hemp was very stunted you
could see all of that Clover emerging it
does not like it it you cannot have that
for a hemp
system the other work that she is uh um
looking at Ashley that is is nitrogen
management we know that this is the
biggest limiting factor when it comes to
nutrients and so Ashley is looking at a
range of of nitrogen rates from zero all
the way up to 250 pounds per acre but
she's also looking at the inclusion of
leguminous cover crops crimson clover
and hary veg right they're fixing
nitrogen over the fall and winter and
then we incorporate that into the the
Fields the idea is that we can use all
of that for our crop and so um this is
just a fun picture of the edge effect if
you've never seen it this is a zero plot
but you could see the edge around the
plot where uh the hemp is basically SCA
scavening for anything it can get and it
looks quite quite different so we always
make sure to harvest within the plot um
we take a lot of data we're doing weekly
measurements Heights and widths we're
looking at chlorophyll we're looking at
Leaf nitrate ammonium and so on and so
forth and then we're looking at these
different uh metrics at Harvest I'm kind
of running out of time so I'm going to
go by these uh these are just U height
data not that interesting I will say
though in Clinton we didn't get great uh
crimson clover uh stands and you could
see that the height wasn't great in
Clinton in our plots that just received
crimson clover and we see a pretty
strong nitrogen effect the yellow and
then the lighter greens are lower
nitrogen and then the darker greens are
higher nitrogen so the higher the
nitrogen the taller the stem but we see
that with our our hary vet that it's
comparable to about 50 to 100 pounds of
nitrogen which is um normally what we
can produce with that cover crop in our
kinson location we saw that both both
cover crops actually did quite well just
in terms of height now um compared to
our other nitrogen treatments and we're
comparable to our 200 250 pounds of
nitrogen so you know we don't think we
need 200 and 250 pounds of nitrogen but
um it certainly does quite well um as
just a pure nitrogen source so keep an
eye out for more of that
research the other work that that
Ashley's doing is looking at reading so
reading is both an art and a science in
the sense that we know that there are a
lot of factors that affect reading we
know that temperature and moisture and
rain and microbes all affect reading but
we don't really know how to measure
those and give good predictions in terms
of if a farmer harvests a crop on July 1
I want to be able to pull down data that
can help them make the decision when to
to pull the the crop out of the field
and so uh what Ashley is doing is she's
uh growing out you know large acreage of
hemp and then she's putting out these
different sensors so we're looking at uh
ambient temperature rainfall uh Leaf
moisture so on and so forth and then
she's pulling stems out on a weekly
basis and what she's going to be doing
there is she's going to be decorticating
them and looking at how easy it is to
decorticate Decor ability and then we're
going to look at the chemical makeup of
the stems so pectin ligant hemicellulose
excuse me so on and so forth and look at
the fiber quality um and this is kind of
what it looks like so we took pictures
throughout this process and you know you
go from Green all the way to this
grayish and then you get these black
splotches on it and so on and so forth
um and you know the thing is we're not
going to say all hemp needs to be
readded at three weeks that's not the
purpose of this project because that's
not how reading works uh instead we want
to understand the temporal effects of
reading but also understand what else uh
really drives reading and so one aspect
that we're looking at is color
traditionally if if you look back most
folks base spreading off of color of
stem and so what we're looking at here
are uh the stems that she pulled out of
the field and they're color so we use a
Colorimeter and what that does is it it
measures the color of an object and it
converts color to basically a
quantitative value so numbers that we
can then analyze and so um the end goal
is we're going to be taking all of these
different data from environmental data
to color to detic ability to all of
these other you know uh stem chemistries
put that into machine Le learning
algorithms and understand what are the
key drivers and then can we use those to
predict ready and that's kind of further
down the line right but the idea is we
know which are say the top three can we
measure those when we Harvest and then
use that algorithm to tell us when to
pull the the crop out of the field and
that's kind of a few years down the
line so um I'm a minute late but I
wanted to end by uh first introducing
and acknowledging someone I have an
amazing team you've already seen a lot
of the hard work that they do but I have
an incredible technician her name is
Shannon Enrique as you know she's
pictured here and I don't know if you
could tell but Shannon has a little baby
bump in this picture so she was working
in the field this summer even though we
told her she should take it easy she
recently had her baby in the fall but
this program is nothing without Shannon
and she does a tremendous job uh and we
are thrilled for her and her her her
newborn um and uh we are so thankful for
the hard work that she does um and I
also want to thank the rest of my and I
will end there and I am happy to take on
questions but the last thing I will do
is um just give you all an open
invitation we love having people down um
you know we we host field days we would
love to have as many people out to visit
with us and if you want to walk through
the fields and look at the different
trials we're doing we'd be more than
happy to to host you similarly if you
want to come visit our College of
textiles which I highly highly recommend
I'd be more than happy to help uh
coordinate those visits so uh with that
I want to thank thank the folks at
Cornell for for giving me this
opportunity and uh I'm willing to take
any
questions so I think you should be able
to open the Q&A box and look at them
yourself
yes okay
um yeah I mean so there are some
questions I see that there's a question
about the uh economic viability of hemp
for grain production we really don't do
a lot of grain production in North
Carolina yet um that industry is not
evolved in our state and we also just
don't really we've got issues with
diseases we'll eventually get there but
that's something I can't really answer
um okay there was a question about uh
THC in Chinese varieties I think I
answered that one yep Aaron looks like
you jumped the gun
um okay Tomas what culture artist would
you recommend for latitudes between 40
and 32 degrees south which correspond to
the center of
Argentina
um umaa Yuma Han and fiber 2 would you
uh okay yeah so uh Tomas the question
about varieties that picture that I I
showed you of Gary syes standing in that
field from hemp grower magazine that
variety I'm pretty sure was Bea brazis
or beab as people like to call it and
it's a great grain variety and I've seen
some people farther north do dual Market
or dual purpose but for our environment
and our day lengths it cannot be used
for fiber simply because of the the
season so um I would say start off with
those Chinese varieties keep an eye out
for what's being produced and developed
in the United States whether it's from
Larry's program but others uh within the
us that are we're seeing a lot more
breeding efforts around fiber for
different latitudes um and when in doubt
what I always tell folks that are
farming if you're ever trying anything
new start small and never invest more
than you're willing to lose right
because you know it may not be the right
variety or or things happen and so you
know if you get some be braisy try a
small plot worth you know and obviously
that's um um it's subjective right small
could be a quarter of an acre to one
person or it could be 10 acres for
someone else but start small I think
that in terms of daylength sensitivity
those Chinese varieties should do well
for you but know too that even within
those there's differences when it comes
to daylength uh sensitivity in that
critical photo
period
um
okay uh TL asked are you planning on
evaluating the hemp spectral signature
for decortication trials that's a great
question so we're we're currently doing
RGB um and that's what I I showed
earlier and we are going to be looking
at using multispectral Imaging as well
um multispec is a little bit challenging
um based both on the amount of data you
generate but then also the applicability
of that data and how good those uh
machine learning algorithms are but but
we will be looking at that um because
it's really frankly just a matter of
taking a picture quote unquote and then
um having the computing power to analyze
that um Michael uh asked if the slide
presentation will be available I can
make some of the slides available but
some with the data because they're
preliminary I can't um but Michael
please reach out to me um if there's
specific information that you'd like I'd
be more than happy to to get it to
you um is hemp susceptible to hop latent
virus I don't know um one of the things
that I've seen with our fiber hemp
trials um in general is fortunately
we've not seen a lot of disease or
insect pest damage now that's not to say
that we don't see insect or disease pest
damage in hemp in North Carolina in our
canabo or floral hemp corn wors will
devastate a crop and there are also
types of uh uh fungal pathogens that
will devastate a crop but since we're
not letting this go to flower we don't
see a lot of those issues the one issue
that I have seen in certain Fields is
sclerotinia soil born disease very Comm
in you know some commodity production
systems um and we can see it affect
fiber hm fortunately we haven't seen it
on a widespread level but it is
something to be um aware of especially
if you're going into Fields where you
know that you're you you've had a
history of that um uh
disease okay Michael you asked a great
question can the fibers be spun on Mach
Machinery that you can spin cotton on
the short answer is no um this is a a
big challenge that the industry has the
reason I say no is that fiber hemp
fibers are much longer than cotton
fibers and so that's why what's
traditionally done at least in the US is
cotton isation all cotton is is cutting
fiber hemp fibers down so that they can
be spun on Cotton equipment now in other
countries like in China they have other
spinning uh equipment uh like wet
spinning and so on where you don't have
to do that in fact some of the folks in
our College of textiles are uh
purchasing some large scale um spinning
equipment that is specifically built for
spinning of long staple fiber so that we
don't have to Cotton it but when you
look across the nation we are built on
Cotton proc excuse me cotton processing
so for the time being if we're going to
use that equipment it's going to have to
be
cottoned are there any fiber processing
in New York I can't answer that I don't
know um I think that there's a lot of
movement in New York for more um I hate
to say industrial applications but more
things like hemp
or um uh construction and and and that
type of application but I'm not sure
Larry smart would be a great person to
ask about
that what varieties were used in our
nitrogen and density study we used Yuma
um cond hemp the company that we got the
seed from uh is just selling Yuma
they're not doing any of the numbered
lines now it's just Yuma um and so
that's what we are using uh for the time
being um until we get some other
varieties that work well in our
uh uh
latitude what are we doing with the
herds Charles that's a great question um
so right now we are more or less just
giving it away to other researchers you
know like in our College of textiles
that are looking at other ways to
valorize herd whether it's pulping and
making um packaging or paper I had a
really interesting really interesting
conversation with a researcher in our
bio andag engineering he says he thinks
he has a microb that can digest it and
we can make a form of whis out of it
which will either be really cool or
really disgusting I don't know um but I
think it would be pretty cool I will
tell you this I will not be the first
person to try it because um it just
sounds sounds dangerous but there are
folks that are working on herd uh
processing here um but uh admittedly in
North Carolina the industry seems to be
much more geared towards Bast production
for the time being but the other thing
to note about fiber hemp is that bass
production alone will I don't think
that's going to be enough for a farmer
when we talk about profit there there's
plenty we can do with herd and farmers
are going to need to be able to benefit
from The Profit they can generate from
the herd as
well Thomas you asked a great question
about turning the hemp yes so in our
reading study and I'm I'm I'm glad you
brought this up I didn't mention this
but at least for the bundles of hemp
that we were pulling out of the field
for analysis asy was going in and
turning them because that's something
that we do in general to get good even
reading um you can leave them in the
field and not turn them but certainly if
you want better reading and faster
reading turning is ideal and so we are
doing
that um share my contact uh Adriano I
hope I'm pronouncing that correctly my
contact information
is I will put it in the webinar chat at
least my email
address I know I'm running through these
quickly but there's a there's a bunch of
questions but he you can cut me off
whenever you
[Music]
want any publication on the ranges of
cellulose and ligant content uh Joan yes
there there's actually a lot of research
out there that has Quantified cellulose
and hemicellulose and Lan in a lot of
feed stocks often it when you look in
the literature it may not necessarily be
a paper on
fiber production but it's just general
feed stock so when they're looking at
like using fiber hemp for biochar or
digesting for um um biofuels those are
the papers where you'll see that
information but there are a few other um
papers that I've seen that are fiber
specific that do also look in the
cellulous content or the ligant content
and so on
um Louise have you seen any effects on
the end rates on reading time and
process processibility luxurious an
uptake can lead to longer writing times
that's super interesting Lise um we
didn't look at that in our nitrogen rate
trial but because you brought that up
I'm going to talk to Ashley about that
that would be really interesting um hemp
certainly will likely do a luxury
consumption of nitrogen um we don't
really think it fiber hemp at least for
for this purpose requires that much we
think it's probably going to be
somewhere around 100 to 150 pounds per
acre maybe less
um but um that's a really interesting
point about um that luxury consumption
what its effects on on reading so thank
you Louise I'm gonna look into that
one
um so there's another question in the in
the webinar chat and I'm going back and
forth what is the performance difference
between dual purpose and fiber only
genetics and the the the main thing here
to understand is is that if you're going
for Dual Purpose that means I'm letting
my plant go to full maturity or at least
to the point where I can Harvest seed
and so that means that it's likely going
to be hard harder to process that stem
there's going to be more ligant in the
stem there's going to be more secondary
fiber in the stem and the fibers will
likely be thicker in general right when
we go back to that the morphology of the
fibers and so that material may not the
fibers I should say may not necessarily
be the best for say like a like a
apparel a shirt or some other type of
texile application um but the other side
of it is in a dual purpose you're
getting grain as well uh and admittedly
I'm quite excited about Dual Purpose um
you know it's going to require a lot
from Machinery investment to harvest
that but I think that's another way for
firms to really maximize yield and
profit
um oh Lord so Maro your question on
business models I'm an agronomist I'm
not going to answer questions on on
business models I apologize um I'm just
not the right person I can certainly um
um put you in touch with folks that are
that handle more of the economics um but
you know I think one one thing I will
tell you in general about the industry
is that we always have this chicken and
egg issue where you have companies that
want the product but they're unwilling
to say invest in processing
infrastructure because they don't see
people growing it
and then you've got Farmers that want to
grow it but they're not going to grow it
because there's nowhere to get it
processed and what what is allowing I
think the industry in North Carolina to
move quickly I shouldn't say quickly but
move at a faster pace is that we are
seeing more processors pop up if you
don't have processing capabilities where
you are it's going to be very hard to
get this crop off the ground so to speak
this industry off the ground um and so I
think you really want to look into
processing but also understanding where
where is the demand who's going to buy
this right even if I build the process
this can process hundreds of Acres
thousands of Acres who's going to buy it
um
okay let's see oh Leo uh can you discuss
the benefits mentioned in regards to
clothing textile made from hemp okay
that's a great question and I will say
that I'm going to venture into a realm
where I I know it enough to be dangerous
but I'm no textile expt
um one of the things that makes the hemp
from fiber really great is is its
durability it is incredibly strong uh
and so where where hemp fits in is when
you think about Denim and you think
about workware like patagon has got
their workware line um anything that is
going to be under a lot of abrasion but
still needs to hold its shape hemp is
highly durable that said I highly doubt
we will ever get to a point where you're
seeing 100% hand shirts and other things
like that because it doesn't wear like
cotton it's not as soft as cotton um
we're often seeing a lot of cotton hemp
Blends so you get the best of both
worlds the other thing that that the
textile industry gets really excited
about is that they see the fibers from
fiber hemp being a replacement for a lot
of the synthetics that are put in a
cotton synthetic blend fill in the blank
shirt sock whatever and there it's a
really cool sustainability store we're
getting rid of these synthetics that are
generated from Oil we're working with
farmers who are growing the cotton and
the fiber hm right and so there's
there's a much better story and you know
it's something that I I think uh I would
love to wear um and there's also a
number of other benefits um some of our
researchers are working with the
military and looking at garments that
have fiber hemp in them uh for folks
that are uh in the Navy or are going to
be in and out of water regularly because
hemp holds it shape much better in water
um and so there are a number of other
benefits there um but it is it is quite
a unique and breathable uh
fiber uh philli can you talk more about
your decortication efforts with your
partners how was that relationship
developed um I don't really understand
the question Phillip
um I if you're talking about the
companies they have basically just been
popping up they they've seen that
there's a need for it and that it wasn't
being met and they're business folks so
they're really trying to get in you know
uh get in as soon as they
can what I really appreciate so far
about the decorators that that that I've
been working with here in North Carolina
is that they understand that this is a
work in progress and they understand
that this is a new crop and they
understand that farmers are going to
have challenges and it's not just purely
business right on so for example some of
the decorators right now are paying more
or less a flat fee for Farmers for a
specific acreage regardless of yields um
they they understand that it's
eventually it will go to much more of a
traditional you know yield quality
system but I appreciate their
willingness to work with the farmer and
to kind of help them along the way as
this industry develops I'm not sure if
that's the question you you meant to ask
but um or or if that's the answer you
wanted but but um I could
certainly answer when you come to North
Carolina which I think you want
um okay uh to what extent if any is the
is Congress FDA stagnation in regulating
cannabinoids impacting the growth of
fiber hemp industry in North Carolina
admittedly not that much um you know it
is a concern right with those Chinese
varieties going hot but that has not
been what's limiting folks mainly it's
just been industry pull and getting
these processors up to speed um the
cannaboid side is certainly a concern
um but it's not limiting producers it's
not keeping producers out I will say
though that the burden of paperwork and
having to get an FBI background check
and all of that to get a license
certainly does keep Farmers from getting
in in hemp that may haven't before and
that's not all of them but some of them
just don't want to do it and frankly I I
don't blame them
um
so I guess in that regard that's where
some of that that governmental burden is
impacting um production and the adoption
of this
crop okay David thank you so much uh for
joining us and um it's now a little bit
past two o'clock but um you answered so
many questions that was really helpful I
think
um you know we'll be getting a recording
of all the hemp webinar talks up onto
the Cornell sips YouTube page in the
near future and um so people can rewatch
this if they're interested or share it
with other people they know would be
interested um but for now I think we're
going to say goodbye until two weeks
from now when we have Trey riddle from
IND hemp who's G to join us oh I'm G
have to join that one thank you all
again this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at
cornell.edu